i have 100 minecraft plots and 100
players hi
these hundred contestants can build
whatever they want and whoever builds
the coolest most epic thing i'll buy it
for them let's go sounds expensive if
you build a honda civic i'll buy you a
honda city okay you build 10 gaming
computers i'll buy you 10 gaming
computers whatever the coolest thing
built is i'll pay for it and also that
dream guy's here again hello three two
one begin
all right all right they're all in their
plots i'm already seeing a lot of black
concrete i feel like that's going to be
like gaming laptop probably i'm going to
go join their discord in yellow all
right attention everybody whoever builds
the coolest thing i will buy it for you
if i would miss the beast i'll get my
own oh my god
what is this see the thing is if this
guy wins i won't even know what to buy
you ooh someone's building a guitar all
right guys comment down below if you
don't think it's a guitar oh this guy's
building a diamond ring oh what if he
uses it to propose that might make me
you know vote for a good old sob story
this guy just wants a dining room table
apparently that's just that's all he
wants just an ikea table this is going
to be a great video there is literally
100 people building right now this is
going to be so insane jimmy come look at
this i don't even know what to buy him
if he wins it says carl it has a c on it
and a k in it so what i i have to let
him use carl for a day that's fair is
that what people think carl is yeah
we're building mcdonald's and we want 20
000 dollars worth of mcdonald's okay we
got this chandler we're gonna win for
sure this is already looking like
mcdonald's as of right now it looks like
they just went dirt why are they looking
at us remember the last episode where i
said the guy built something that said
bruh and meme and then just left yeah he
did it again
and then just left he didn't want 10
grand he doesn't want a random item he
just wants to troll and you got to
respect it i love this guy chris yes if
this video right here gets 1 million
likes i will do everything in my power
to have dream verse techno in a 1v1 and
i will put up a hundred thousand dollars
to give to whoever wins do it we have to
know who's better dream or techno it
decides it all i won a hundred thousand
dollars please like the video
it's not even a competition for dreams
okay so dream if i put up a hundred
grand you'll fight techno depending on
the circumstances but almost definitely
yes it has to be the new playstation oh
my gosh no what if we got them that uh
the wireless router that looked like the
playstation he's putting it up there so
we know a hundred percent i didn't
you're about what's up abyss trying to
make a monitor it's called the predator
monitor you know it looks pretty cool
the base is looking really good so far
man i like it i love you abyss this
person's building your car if he wins
he's gonna run me up that's gonna be
expensive all right what's up a typical
club what kind of car is this uh i've
just searched up honda civic just
because tesla is probably way too
expensive usually i roast contestants
but genuinely i hope you win and i want
to buy you a car all right thank you is
he gone
i'm still here
no that's gotta go in
hey a dream you're right it is a guitar
oh yeah i'm a genius oh dude look at the
strings on it that's so cool meanwhile
mcdonald's bro look at the talkies bag
what are you guys building um i guess
you'll find out you haven't built
anything yet it's the foundation all
right well if i don't get him no no
doing this until i get a hit what's a
hint okay okay okay okay it's food
related food related okay that's all he
had to say this guy's building minecraft
on a pc this one right here is pretty
dope so he's got a pewdiepie chair a pc
and a monitor i'm actually kind of
digging it oh this guy wasn't building a
table he wants a gaming setup too
there's a lot of gaming setups here hey
jimmy this build's gonna be expensive if
it wins look at all these diamonds you
gotta buy so he literally just laid a
bunch of diamonds and then he just left
what is wrong with you guys he was like
all right that'll do
that will win that'll give mr beast
enough content we gonna buy a panda dog
joe exotic got you bud this guy just
wants a glass of pepsi i feel like we
can all respect that is it a glass of
pepsi or does he want a 55 gallon drum
of pepsi hey chris it's just one normal
can we should let this guy win so we
could save a lot of money i just have to
buy him a one dollar can dream can you
give me an address to send you stuff and
can i make a giant care package just
full of dumb things and send it to you i
do have a p.o box i do have a p.o box
comment down below what i should put in
dreams care package i'm going to buy a
giant box fill it with stupid stuff and
i'm going to comment a million dollars a
million dollars everybody just comment
send dream a million dollars comment
baloney let's send
a drum of below what if we send him a
giant box just full of mayonnaise it's
just in the box in the cardboard yeah
this guy wants vr look he wants he's
building like a vr set and he's playing
it and showing you how happy he would be
in it this guy is a genius he built one
bitcoin oh oh nkay that is actually
pretty creative wait a minute this guy
went over the limit this guy went
outside the boundaries we don't tolerate
cheaters goodbye oh
his final words yes this is this is his
final goodbye i'm gonna see what
everybody else is up to okay oh this
gaming pc is water cooling with actual
water oh this guy made it oculus rift
are you just gonna send this guy a boat
if he wins yeah oh this guy i know
what's coming next he's making a
briefcase full of money i can send him a
briefcase full of money oh this guy's
building our merch he wants our merch
lame
oh this guy wants college what a loser i
imagine having to compete in a minecraft
contest to pay for your college that's
how you know college is way too
expensive what's up ish it started as a
joke but i'm really trying to get this
prius now
yeah i remember from the store video in
this clip thank you i would like a prius
please thank you hopefully you can one
day win a prius on the on our channel
i'm going for it man i'm going for it
we're probably like the only channel on
youtube where it would become a meme for
us to buy someone a car i'm gonna go
check in on chandler and carl again 15
minutes 15 minutes left oh you're
building a mcdonald's so if you win i
have to buy you a mcdonald's restaurant
you guys want a franchise yeah baby okay
leave us alone we got to work there's
only 15 minutes left okay then leave us
alone the challenge is coming to a close
we have like one or two minutes left
we'll just look at it look at all the
crazy stuff everyone built attention
everybody the time is now off judging
shall begin make sure you're standing
near your project good luck everybody
only one of you will win
who's this get away why is jimmy here he
can't build anymore the challenge is now
over and we will begin raiding we'll
start with this one mr beast 100 million
subscribers i don't know how you buy 100
million subscribers next wait what is
this this is two light sabers at least
he knows what he wants electricity bill
more on fun payments rent vet bills it
looks like the car i drew when i was in
k5
is this a golden apple watch oh this
guy's got it right i'll give him a six
out of ten yeah six out of ten four next
next this john what a house i think the
house is pretty cool i'm gonna give it a
six
does it even qualify i mean like i mean
what are we going to buy them we'll buy
them a house what am i not mr beast all
right i'm calling your bluff 10 10.
all right well that's only 26. let's
make jimmy go bankrupt this one took
some effort so he's got a big chair big
pc big keyboard triple monitor setup i
give it a nine really nice i'm gonna
give it a nine as well i'll give it a
seven it's pretty good you just want me
to have to buy the house look dream come
here the mouse even has buttons on it
look and it's got the side buttons too
all right this guy built the boat hey
jimmy i ship it get it i'm standing on a
ship
i give it a one out of ten what do you
guys give it one out of ten all right
what pretty good i'll give it i'll give
it a seven all right so this guy's all
over the place he wants a pc a diamond
ring gold bars cash and an iphone yeah
the next one's amazing they came back
and put bra meme gang next all right
this is pretty cool this is a pinball
game pinball machine i like what he did
with the cobwebs it's piece designed
i'll give him a nine oh i'll give him an
eight i think it's pretty cool actually
six you just ruined his chances but look
look at the inside look at the inside
there's not that much in there hey well
they're here they're
here they're still building even though
they're cheating they're cheating
disqualified i'm gonna abandon both
sorry phantom
show us our score yo
what the heck why
okay this this is a little creative he
pivoted the road to his car oh so he can
like drive out all right i'm giving him
an 8 out of 10. i'll give him a 7 out of
10. i'm going to rate it a 9. still not
in first place next is it not oh man the
creeper isn't finished 10 out of 10.
what are you ready 10 out of 10. it's
not fit one out of 10. okay
thank god we have three that's a voice
of reason here i'm a big rv fan 10 out
of 10. i give it i give it an eight it's
pretty good honestly i give it a nine i
i like the scenery with the rv that's 27
points so now this rv is actually in
first place all right good you don't
have to buy a house now i hope he can at
least drive so this is the prius he
never did anything with the ground but
he's got this guy hanging out the window
surfing i
honestly i give it a 10. i'm going to
give it a nine could he use a little bit
more detail i'll give him an
eight turkey get off my swallow
be swoop track his love
shrek his life next next this guy wants
his college paid for i'm gonna say 10. i
really nine what i like about this build
is it's original he didn't steal this
from the internet so i'll give him a
nine so as of right now if no one else
is better this dude's college tuition is
paid for this gaming setup is amazing
let's read the science first i build
this for me and my homies gg if i lose
though love from lithuania he wants
gaming setups for the boys we only gave
them an hour and this is pretty big so
i'm gonna give him a 10 out of 10. i'm
gonna give him a nine chris
your rating decides if he and the boys
get computer i don't like this pressure
10 it's for the boys it's for the boys
yo fire lotus your build is in first
place okay so we still have some more to
rate but if the other ones suck
you and the boys are getting your
computers for the boys yeah
this is the ultimate collector series
millennium falcon there were better
builds unfortunately so you didn't win
but dream really liked you and he wanted
to give you a chance to win this by
playing him in rock paper scissors we're
gonna turn our back to each other and
then on three we're both gonna hold
whatever item like we wanna use okay
rock paper scissors shoot
dream got the dub
that's one that's one rock paper
scissors shoot
hey
all right sell one he picks scissors
rock paper scissors shoot
still got the door
[Applause]
he's getting the lego set
congrats on the lego set and with that
said and done that means this gentleman
who built the setup for the boys
got the dub fire lotus
congratulations you got second place
what yeah sorry see that pac-man machine
it won yeah just kidding you got the
dove and you and the boys are getting
brand new gaming setups thank you if the
boys are happy we're happy hit that
subscribe button and we'll see you in
the next video bye